today I feel happy and motivated and
grateful that social media influencer
Jackie Miller James in better times she
recently suffered a medical emergency
that put her in a coma after suffering
an aneurysm rupture that caused severe
bleeding tragically this happened when
the digital Creator was nine months
pregnant with her first child and at the
time her due date was just one week away
on a GoFundMe page started by Jackie's
sisters they revealed Jackie was found
by her husband Austin James who rushed
her to the ER where she immediately had
a C-section and her baby seen here with
Jackie and her medically induced coma
was in the NICU for 12 days you realize
there is no such thing as normal no one
has a perfect normal life and in fact we
are all connected by the one thing we
have in common which is that none of us
are normal Jackie's best known for her
beauty and lifestyle content on
Instagram where she shares content
across multiple platforms Jackie's
Community has already raised 140
thousand dollars with over two thousand
donations her family says so far she's
had five operations and she's expected
to remain in the ICU for weeks followed
by months spent at the hospital it can
be really scary and vulnerable to start
opening up about how you're feeling and
what you're experiencing but when you do
you realize so many others are feeling
and experiencing things very similar